faire confiance en ce nouveau sous-marin
en matériau composite il avait néanmoins
voulu en être pour la beauté de
l'expédition la coque en fibres de
carbone permet un gain de poids
important car sa densité est inférieure
à celle du titane et de l'acier
généralement utilisé pour la conception
des sous-marins le poids du Titan 10
tonnes seulement contre 20 pour les
autres sous-marins scientifiques
s'avérer donc plus pratique dans les
phases hors de l'eau mais reste une
inconnue comment les différentes
matières de la coque qui allient des
matériaux composites mais aussi des
alliages métalliques travaillent les
unes par rapport aux autres sont de
grosses contraintes
le hublot de 60 cm installé à l'avant de
l'appareil pourrait aussi constituer une
faille la taille de cet orifice
démesurée pour être très bien constitué
un point de fragilité à sa jonction avec
la coque alors y a-t-il eu des défauts
dans la conception du Titan le Titan
c'était déjà perdu pendant deux heures
et demie lors de sa dernière expédition
à l'été 2022 mais ce sont surtout des
documents judiciaires de 2018 qui ont
refait surface durant la tragédie dans
ceci l'ancien directeur des opérations
marines d'ochengate David lochrich avait
soulevé des problèmes de sécurité
important et regretter l'absence de test
avant d'être licencié pour l'heure il
est impossible de donner les raisons
précises de l'implosion seuls les débris
trouvés pourraient donner plus
d'informations mais il n'est pas certain
qu'ils apportent des réponses au vu de
la violence de l'implosion